another thing that trump is doing which
is
some people might view it as the
opposite of saving lives i don't view it
this way but
while he's trying to make sure americans
get this vaccine he's also ramping up
executions for people on death row
which i think is actually an important
way to save lives but it's a little bit
indirect because you're saving lives by
by killing criminals who
who have been sentenced to death if
the updated schedule of the executions
is carried off president trump
would become the most prolific execution
president
in over 130 years i think this is a very
good
thing i know there is disagreement the
left is very anti-death penalty
even many conservatives are anti-death
penalty
i am not anti-death penalty i think the
death penalty is very misunderstood
i think it's very important as a matter
of justice i think as our conceptions
of justice in this country are
completely distorted and perverted and
we replace
real justice with a sort of liberal
bastardization of social justice
i think it's important in a country that
is a free country and has law and order
that we have justice all the way up to
including capital punishment
that is because there is a deterrent
effect of capital punishment it's not a
very strong effect right now
because people languish on death row for
30 years that's one of the problems
trump is trying to
fix there is a
retributive aspect of capital punishment
which is the purpose that is the primary
purpose
of criminal justice the primary purpose
is not rehabilitation the primary
purpose is not deterrence it is
retribution because
someone has committed a crime that's why
it's called justice that's why it's not
called criminal rehabilitation system or
criminal deterrent system it's called
the criminal justice system
give people what they deserve there is
mercy as well we have a pardon power but
there's also justice we can't have only
mercy
we can't have only justice without any
mercy but we need the justice component
too
and there's a rehabilitative component
because hanging concentrates the mind
very well
some people are calling for these
executions to be put off nobody's
allowed to
kill the people on death row all these
poor people they committed a crime
so long ago oh it's they made a mistake
let them off the hook
you notice that the people who are
calling for these executions to be
descheduled and for these criminals to
be pardoned they never talk about the
specifics
when they do talk about specifics they
say he was so young he was 18 when he
committed the crime
or he's black or she's black and so
because they're they've
this particular race you can't it's bad
to execute them or something
they never talk about the crimes very
quickly
bernard brandon bernard this is an
execution scheduled for thursday
the left is in overdrive trying to get
this execution
descheduled we actually mentioned
brandon bernard some months ago on the
show
bernard killed two youth ministers todd
and stacy bagley in killen texas
in 1999 he asked them for a ride he was
hitchhiking these two youth ministers
out of the goodness of their heart pull
over give him a ride
he then takes out a gun he holds them
captive
he beats them he throws them
in the trunk of their own car he then
drives them around for a very long time
as he's spending their money
trying to purchase things selling their
possessions
as they are pleading for their lives
they're reading him scripture
he then shoots them both but he doesn't
end up killing the woman
so then he sets the trunk of the car on
fire and burns her alive
it was so long ago though right come on
he was young
you know we all make mistakes okay we
all
kidnap our benefactors rob them
torture them for hours shoot them and
burn them alive right
we all do we all make that mistake come
on what kind of a just country
would execute that man uh i think age
any just country would execute that man
and a country that has no sense of
justice would deschedule that execution
alfred bourgeois tortured and killed his
two-year-old daughter
whom he regularly abused physically and
sexually
he killed her because he had a brief
moment of custody when his his the
mother of this daughter lost custody
just a very brief time he killed her
because
she tipped over her potty training chair
in his flatbed truck
so he slammed her head into a truck
window killed her
oh we have come on it was so long ago
come on what kind of a just country
would kill that man
any just country corey johnson murdered
seven people seven people
uh spurred into this crime because he
wanted to further his drug trafficking
operation
he ended up killing his intended victims
family members and acquaintances too so
it wasn't even just
other people involved in the drug
trafficking ring customers who didn't
pay which were some of his victims or
other rival drug traffickers wasn't even
just them it was also
family members and acquaintances oh no
he only killed seven people he only
ended seven lives
come on we we would be so awful if we if
we killed him
dustin john higgs kidnapped and murdered
three women this was premeditated this
was in cold blood
and finally lisa montgomery who
strangled a pregnant woman to death you
might remember this story he's very
famous at the time bobby jo
stinnett she strangled a pregnant woman
to death cut open her body kidnapped her
baby
but that was so long ago right that's
part of the problem
that's part of the problem
this has gone on too long frankly i
think that
i don't think that the capital
punishment by any measure could be
called cruel and unusual punishment
it's not it's never been unusual in the
entire history of the world and it's not
particularly
cruel compared to say life in prison i
think
that is as a historical fact that is
unusual
and i think that is cruel part of the
reason that we
have lost our sense of justice here is
because we've gone from being a
christian culture to being a materialist
culture
so we now believe that the worst thing
that can possibly happen to someone
is physical death because we have no
sense of the spirit of the soul
of the eternal moral order so now we
just think it's all about flesh and meat
the minute you die it's the worst thing
that could possibly happen
i don't think that's necessarily true
i think there are things worse than
physical death and it's i think it's
very important
that president trump continue on his
path and ramp up these executions
if these people languish on death row
too long the answer to that is not to
pardon all of them
it's to kill them faster this
is a you see you see the defenses of
capital punishment
not just in scripture not just in moral
philosophy but we know them
intuitively that this is not a demand
for
revenge we're not saying vigilante
should go out and kill their enemies
the state has a role in exacting justice
and it ain't just giving out parking
tickets it goes all the way up good
stuff from president trump because by
the way if these are delayed
in any way and if biden does become
president then he's going to have to
deschedule
these he's going to have to explain why
these
monsters should be pardoned
why these monsters should not receive
their just punishment
he's going to have to explain that to
the victims and the victims fam not i
guess not the victims but to the victims
families
[Music]
[Music]
you